I want to punch her in her [ __ ] face I
want them to hurt like I hurt what can I
say this story is full of some crazy
you've been very vocal against the
backlash that has come with the show
people have now seen beyond the trailer
they've seen a couple episodes and
there's still a little bit of
controversy what's your response to them
now I think that people bring with them
their own emotional history and you know
I think that's what makes art amazing
and what makes TV entertaining and you
know I'm completely aware that it's not
a show for everybody but we're we're
really proud of what we did and I think
that people at the very least it will be
a conversation starter somatically
throughout the season people will look
at it and be able to really pinpoint all
the issues that we deal with and have a
conversation about them I think we we
hear and see and acknowledge some of the
backlash I think for us I know the show
that I signed on for and I am very proud
of what we've done and it makes me
really happy that people are seeing it
and you know well I'm totally aware of
it there's so much overwhelming positive
excitement and people being like
literally me you know and relating and
being so hyped and planning parties and
themed things and making memes and it's
just it's cool to see that it's already
part of the culture and the
conversations
that's what makes it so fun
[Music]